I don't know if you
remember but you uh were aboard uh new
Shepherd on its first crude
flight uh how was that experience were
you were you terrified then you know
Strangely I wasn't you know I you ride
the
rocket okay I've watched other people
ride in the rocket and I'm more nervous
than when I was inside the rocket myself
um it was a difficult conversation to
have with my mother uh when I told her I
was going to go on the first one and Not
only was I going to go but I was going
to bring my brother too this is a tough
conversation to have with a mom and
there's a long pause told her like both
of you um
and it was an incredible experience and
we were we were laughing in inside the
capsule and you know we not nervous
um the people on the ground were very
nervous for us um U it was actually one
of the most emotionally powerful parts
of the experience was not happened even
before the flight at 4:30 in the morning
brother and I are getting ready to go to
the launch site and Lauren is going to
take us there in her helicopter and
we're getting ready to leave and we go
outside outside the ranch house there in
West Texas where the launch facility is
and all of our family my kids and my
brother's kids and our you know our our
our parents and uh close friends are
assembled there and they're saying
goodbye to us but they're kind of saying
maybe they think they're saying goodbye
to us
forever and you know we might not have
felt that way but it was obvious from
their faces how nervous they were that
they felt that way and it was sort of
powerful because it allowed us to see it
was almost like attending your own
memorial service or something like you
could feel how loved you were in that
moment um and it was uh it was really
amazing yeah and I mean there's just a
epic nature to it too the asent the
floating of zero gravity I'll tell you
something very interesting zero gravity
feels very natural I don't know if it's
because we you know it's like return to
the womb You're an Alien but
that's I think that's what I think
that's what you just said feels so
natural to be in Zur it was really
interesting and then what people talk
about the overview effect and seeing
Earth from space I had that feeling very
powerfully I think everyone did um you
see how fragile the Earth is if you're
not an environmentalist it will make you
one uh the the great Jim level quote you
know he looked back at the Earth from
space and he said he realized you don't
go to heaven when you die you go to
heaven when you're born and it's just
you know that's the feeling that people
get when they're in space you see all
this Blackness all this nothingness and
there's one Gem of life and it's Earth
it is a gem uh what you know you're
you've talked a lot about decision
making throughout your time with Amazon
what was that decision like to uh to
ride to be the first to ride your
Shepherd like what just be before you
talk to your mom
yeah what what like the pros and cons
like actually as one human being as a as
a leader of a
company um on all fronts like what was
that decision make you like I decided
that U first of all I knew the vehicle
extremely well I know the team who built
it I know the vehicle um the uh I'm very
comfortable with the like the Escape
system we put as much effort into the
Escape system on that vehicle as we put
into all the rest of the vehicle
combined it's one of the hardest pieces
of Engineering in the entire new
Shephard architecture can you actually
describe what do you mean by Escape
system what's involved we have a solid
rocket motor in the base of the crew
capsule so that if anything goes wrong
on
Ascent you know while the main rocket
engine is
firing we can ignite this solid rocket
motor in the base of the crew capsule
and escape from the booster it's a very
challenging system to build design
validate test all of these things it is
the reason that I am comfortable letting
anyone go on new Shepherd so the the the
booster is as safe and reliable as we
can make it but um we are harnessing
whenever you're talking about rocket
engines I don't care what rocket engine
you're talking about you are harnessing
such vast power in such a small compact
geometric space the power density is so
enormous that it is impossible to ever
be sure that nothing will go wrong and
so the only way to um improve safety is
to have an escape system and you know
and historically Rockets human rated
Rockets have had Escape systems only the
space shuttle
did not and um but Apollo had one um the
you know um all of the previous you know
Gemini Etc they all had Escape
systems and uh we have on new Shepherd
unusual Escape most Escape systems are
Towers we have a pusher Escape system so
the solid rocket motor is actually
embedded in the base of the crew capsule
and it pushes and it's reusable in the
sense that if we don't use it so if we
have a nominal mission we land with it
the tower systems have to be ejected at
a certain point in the mission and so
they get wasted even in a nominal
Mission and so again you know cost
really matters on these things so we
figured out how to have the Escape
system be a reusable in the event that
it's not used you can reuse it um and
have it be a pusher system it's a very
sophisticated thing so I knew these
things you asked me about my decision to
go and so I know the vehicle very well I
know the people who uh Des find it I had
great trust in them um and in the
engineering that we did uh and I thought
to myself look if I am not ready to go
then I wouldn't want anyone to go a
tourism vehicle has to be designed in my
view to have very to be as safe as one
can make it you can't make it perfectly
safe it's
impossible but you know you have to you
people will do things people take risk
you know they climb mountains they you
know they Skydive they you know do deep
underwater scuba diving and so on people
are okay taking risk you can't eliminate
the risk but it is something because
it's a tourism vehicle you have to do
your utmost to eliminate those risks and
I felt very good about the system I
think it's one of the reasons I was so
calm inside and maybe others weren't
just calm they didn't know as much about
it as I did who was in charge of
engaging the Escape system did you have
it's automated okay the Escape system is
visual is completely automated automated
is better because it can react so much
faster so yeah for for tourism Rockets
safety is a huge huge huge priority for
space exploration also but a a t you
know a Delta less yes I mean I think for
you know if you're doing you know there
are human activities where we tolerate
more risk if you're saving somebody's
life you know um if you are you know
engaging in real exploration um these
things where you know I personally think
you we would accept more risk in part
because you have
to